these drop your takes in the chat uh and
we shall discuss do you guys have any I
will say we already have we already have
one from trig away saying Mark answers I
know it was dropped earlier uh do we do
we have a lien there
I like it but I'm biased but like in all
honesty I'm biased because he's on my
fantasy team but like me being real he
is do and he's Lamar Jackson's favorite
Target so I'll just say that but uh
I'm biased I don't I don't hate that at
all I think we should we should decide
as a family right now uh and I'd Cur I'd
be curious the chats take as well do we
want to like go big with this and like
yes like Mark Andrews I'm looking right
now plus 125. you're gonna go big with
this and try and like hit a you know
Monster one or do we want to play it
safer and you know play with your Derek
Henry's Christian McCaffrey's in the
world because I can be talked into
either so I'm curious your take I'm
curious the chats take
um and just philosophically how we want
to build this
that's a great question Sam I mean I I
woke up this morning I'm not gonna lie
like God I woke up this morning saying
we need to add Christian McCaffrey to
our touchdown parlay because he's going
to score like I I I I I I I don't know
it was a being from God that went
through my window and went to me and
just told me Crystal McCaffrey is going
to score today so I'm I'm just giving
that to the chat just letting you guys
know because we know how to deal with
this parlay yeah we're just throwing it
out there I did get the beam from God
Christian McCaffrey
he's gonna score today but uh let's
let's look let's let's look Mark Andrews
sitting that plus 125 I'm about to hop
into the to come and see what they're
talking about yeah Ryan what's the chat
saying yeah so uh well Mike Ritter wants
us to go big or go home so that there's
a taking the chat there uh yeah so we
have a lot of Mark Andrews we have a lot
of Mark edgers in here there is a lot of
uh for Maddie 2x Jeff Wilson so I mean
that kind of like it comes down to a
philosophical thing right so if it's if
we're saying with Greg it's like we're
gonna grab we're gonna add Christian
McCaffrey then I don't think we can
necessarily do a Jeff Wilson who let me
pull this up right here Jeff Wilson is
-220. like I think there needs to kind
of be a little bit of a punch mix and
match mix and match exactly like I don't
I don't want to go too heavy on one what
about I got trigger away our guy trigger
way he said one of my favorite picks and
you guys might laugh when I say this
Kenneth Walker III
Kenneth Walker the third he is the Bell
cow in Seattle they're playing the
Raiders they don't even know how to they
don't know what stopping the run is out
there then this is me guys can I ask you
a question do we want to build a parlor
here or do we want to rebuild your
fantasy team live on air
because I as I think that's sort of
where we're leading but I mean hey well
you know when your fantasy team is full
of hitters you know what I'm saying like
I you can just chills on who's going to
score I don't just like Kenneth Walker
at all I I think that Raiders team is is
very getable
um that's funny that you know he's on my
fantasy team but he is hey we need a
pick though guys we need to lock
something in
um I I do like McCaffrey espec like if
Greg is saying that he got a beam of
light from God and we don't take that
that I just feel like is bad vibes so
the chat is with it I think we have to
take that
we we
I think we're going to take
but I'm seeing Walker I'm seeing a lot
of
Kenneth Walker III
we need juice bro we're getting
squeeze we can't follow we have to
follow the the fans are picking Ryan
this isn't your parlay I know but
they're giving some plus money plays
we're ignoring it okay so let's just
let's just try all right so let's go
let's just see what it looks like what
um what is the payout for McCaffrey
Andrews and
uh Kenneth Walker let's just let's just
let's just take a look let's see what
the payout is we'll take a look last the
chat
not enough for me not enough foreign
that's a win bro like do you not want us
it's a win like I think we need the chat
to decide this for us so just chat yeah
spam it yes or no just like you've got
30 seconds yes or no do we ride with
this or do we do we take all right so
why but hold on hold on yeah yeah while
we wait for the chat I I want to ask
Ryan what
plus 480 with like what else do you need
bro I I want somebody to jump in here
with a PL like a little bit more of a
plus money take that and see and then
we've got the onions jumping in here
with uh Amari Cooper I don't hate that
like Amari Cooper is plus elements in
the elements so so basically you don't
want us to win just say that bro don't
say you don't want us to win it's just
like a plus 483 like any time touchdown
is not this is just like your classic
group chat oh by the way it's like do we
do we try and go for the win or do we go
for the Hail Mary that's what I'm saying
make the decision hold up hold up I got
the answer from the chat no the answer
is no be I'll read them off just in case
you don't believe me head of WP no B
Wilson 27 no uh coach Abdul no hip dog
no shall I continue see Thomas Ted no no
okay okay all right all right okay all
right so we need the boys in there and
we do need to to finish this parlay
we're taking on Eastern so we have an
hour and 40 minutes live on air for us
to finish this parlor bro people are in
the chat saying who was Kenneth Walker
they need to go
Google who that man is he's been leading
the scene he's going to win rookie of
the year yeah Google here yeah all right
uh
Mike Ritter jumping in here okay
Christian Watson
what is it when I said his last two
games yes and what is he he is Plus 260.
guys that's 12.
see this is where I separate myself
because
um
I don't know man I'ma be honest I don't
know y'all can do this if y'all want to
do this y'all can do this NPR I don't
know to decide the parlay though I don't
want Ritter decide it okay okay and mpo
94 Christian Watson
James stew waddle that's minus 115
though again I want more I want more G
I'm asking the chat for juice I'm asking
the chat to be a little bit more
creative than the minus 260 plays that
we're getting
I want us to get rich Greg I want to win
I don't man plus four or six if we could
if we win we're gonna get rich as much
as you win you're gonna get rich plus
460 is gonna pay for my next coffee
I want a PS5
you know what we should do we should
have we should have Ryan
yeah
and Greg's parlay and you guys should
just go head to head you guys should
each build one
take a little 1v1 laughs whoever hits
the most legs uh wins a prize
um
mha B4 says coconut hold on
how you skip on it Jay jones615 he says
he's being greedy that's what Ryan is
being Ryan is being greedy right now I'm
trying to see a win he wants to get rich
I yes I think we all want to get rich I
think if you were to ask the chat what's
your goal they would say get rich
I agree but but I also a few ones I I
feel like if we ask the chat okay Ricky
03. they will say yeah yes we all want
to win right Ricky 03 Chris olave
I don't love that no I like that he's on
my team I like that yeah but we already
have it we can't we can't we have
Christian McCaffrey in here
hey he's on my face he's on Greg's
fantasy team
but we put we we already have Christian
McCaffrey so actually that was that was
on me for reading not we can't do that
uh
oh same game yeah yeah
uh wait so which which I'm sorry Ryan
I'm sorry Sam which which picks do we
have locked in because we gotta go guys
we've been speaking a lot of time I know
I know I know Christian McCaffrey Mark
Andrews Christian Watson
we don't have lots in lockdown
yeah Watson's is not locked here what
about what about chub instead of Watson
do we like that
I like joke
somebody dropped somebody dropped DK
Metcalf
but then with Greg like then we're gonna
lose
how do we go with
I go with Kenneth Walker and go with DK
Metcalf like we know Kenneth Walker is
going to get the ball in his hands an x
amount of times we don't know if
all right all right all right all right
what is Nick show what is Nick Chubb
what is Nick minus 125.
you guys
Brian you're killing me bro I was you
took the words right out of my mouth
you're killing me I really think you
guys should just each make one and go
head-to-head plus 550. I don't have
enough time to put together three like
parlay now we got we gotta go plus 550
what do you guys want to do if we do
Nick job it's mine it's plus 550 if we
were to take out Nick Chubb and put in
say DK Metcalf no why will we do that
all right so then we're not doing that
we're not doing that then this is it I
think I by executive decision is we put
Kenneth Walker back in thank you sad
with the original parlay we live and die
with it if Craig crashes we obviously
Greg will have bragging rights over you
yes and it's DK madcap scores instead of
Kenneth Walker you'll get to roast him
but you know
ryan's.com if Christian Watson scores I
want you guys to know you may don't even
show up next week I will be unbearable
you would Nobel Peace Prize last week no
it's out the window I'd hand it back in
So This is
Christian McCaffrey Mark Andrews Kenneth
Walker III three pick parlay Plus 480.
this is the anytime touchdown parlay
this week on DraftKings
boom it's done there it is
and it wouldn't be Sunday if I didn't
get to do a little any time TD boost
magic so we're gonna boost Tyreek Hill
anytime touchdown from minus 140.
to minus 110. we boosted him up my man
Tyree go get a touchdown I'm over here
literally crying laughing my man Ryan is
super funny
Vibes 11 Vibes speaking of parlay
speaking of parlays if you tapped in on
Thanksgiving I cooked up a little
alternate spread parlay Sam
and it hit so you know what I'm Gonna
Keep The Vibes going we're you know we
hit on Thursday so we're gonna keep
those vibes going and I got another one
Ryan let's pull up those DraftKings odds
please
okay my man Ryan's on it let's go to
that top game right there Baltimore
Ravens Jacksonville Jaguars if you click
it
let's stay on the Raven side and go keep
scrolling to plus three and a half for
the Baltimore Ravens okay
Ravens plus three and a half we're gonna
lock it in then let's go to San
Francisco 49ers let's go to the San
Francisco 49ers game they're taking on
those New Orleans Saints uh in Santa
Clara uh go to the Niners and go to
minus three for the San Francisco 49ers
I I think this one might get ugly out
there to be honest Sam I I think it
might get ugly and Santa Clara but uh
we're just gonna be modest we're just
gonna be modest take the minus three Sam
you always ask me and I know Ryan might
get happy because he wants to get rich
you always ask me is this gonna be plus
money is this gonna be plus money we are
about to find out let's go to the
fighting Jeff Saturdays the fighting
Jeff Saturdays
plus three for the fighting Jeff
Saturdays they're taking on the
Pittsburgh Steelers and their rookie
quarterback
plus 164. hey and frisky hey
it's as good as it's better than even
money you can just go sit down watch the
games throughout the day relax and hit a
parlay and double your money actually
double it up a little bit more uh there
it is though there it is Ryan there it
is Sam thoughts
I well I think we just need to have a
larger discussion because obviously
everyone says like Greg never wins but I
think at this point I think it might be
Greg only wins I mean just just look at
the last few weeks
Sam real real G's move in silence like
lasagna that's why I gotta say it for
you you can't say it I gotta say it for
you hey so it's up to them they they're
either going to catch on or they're not
Ryan are you digging the parlay Yes No
Maybe So yeah I love it I don't I don't
see why each of these legs can't hit and
at the end of the day Ryan just looks
broken I think I don't want to talk
about what's broken after the anytime TD
debacle I don't want to talk about this
watching him scroll is just like the
life was leaving his eyes I haven't
spoken in like two minutes I can't
is plus 480 I mean we should have done
it if you don't leave this show Ryan and
build an anytime Genie parlay with
Christian Watson and all your guys in it
I'm gonna be disappointed I have a
separate I have a separate one going
that's 17 again so we're good yeah yeah
yeah yeah make sure you tweet it make
sure you tweet it so we can ride with
you bro because I want to know I want to
know if your juice if you're if you're
getting rich strategy is going to work
today but Ryan you this is my bet what
what are you rocking with today uh so it
gets as simple as this right if there
was a hall of fame for three and and
seven teams the Jacksonville Jaguars
would be in it but there's not a hall of
fame for three and seven teams uh it's
like I'm like Denzel and Remember the
Titans you're a Hall of Famer in my book
the Jacksonville Jaguars are actually a
good team they just their record doesn't
show it they have only lost one game and
it was last week by more than one score
and today they play the Baltimore Ravens
who are living on borrowed time they're
on a four game win streak but they have
not been that impressive Sam I know
they're you're all in team but I love
the Jags plus three and a half today I
actually think they're coming off a buy
you're gonna get them fresh I think they
lead for most of this game they may win
but we're gonna take the points at plus
three and a half I love the Jaguars
today I love them I love them I love
them
there it is a little head to head
because Greg's parlay obviously has the
Raven so just continuing this trend we
can again I'm just sort of trying to
foster a rivalry I'm just trying to kind
of throw the match and let this explode
we get both well we could both win we
talked about it before the show we
talked about it before his show uh me
and Ryan we're good we're boys we're
boys we we might butt head a little bit
but we're boys
at the end of the day we make up and we
win you know what I mean because last
week we put ahead
and then we won
but uh I still don't think the 12-1 play
is the way to go but anyway oh
Ryan let's talk to the people let's talk
to the chat see what they're talking
about uh twin number two uh in all caps
Here We Go Again Greg and Ryan we said
we squashed the beef we're done
um but all right uh let's see let's see
what we got because I think it's time to
grade some bets
um
need some locks in here uh trig away
Dolphins first half uh minus nine and a
half
yeah and I say that as someone who's bad
on the Texans like they if they get 50
yards and a half it's like a good
performance by them they that's just the
most inept offense I've ever seen so
um I I really don't hate it's a lot to
lay in a first half but I can't say I
hate it so I would give it like a B
minus not something that I would play
just because this league is insane and
beating a team by 10 and a half is a lot
to ask but I I don't hate it at all
yeah I wonder if that Line's valid that
might be an alternate spread because
I I see the lines at 14 and 10 and a
half for the first half on a line that's
14 I don't know so
um I'm gonna give it a
give it a c minus because I don't know
if that's valid or not it is the first
half of the first half is minus is it
half it's minus eight and a half on
drafting minus eight and a half minus
eight and a half and they said minus ten
and that minus seven minus nine and a
half
go get the line now go get it uh said
Logan the Bears
the bears plus it doesn't have
Justin Fields playing is he playing nope
no
exactly
but Mike White but Mike White yeah to me
to me it's a stay away the Bears roster
outside of fields like absolutely stinks
um but you're still laying 7.6 and a
half points with Mike White so to me
that's that's a stay away
um so I'll give it an accuracy no let's
see I don't hate the bed I just don't
love it to me it's just a stable yeah
yeah stay away for sure I'm right there
with you Sam all right
um
c c loso DeAndre Hopkins anytime TD Plus
100.
yeah I think because it corresponds with
what I'm betting so uh an A A minus okay
all right all right we tried to be right
on the nose to get that to get that flat
a but
no since D hot hey speaking of fantasy
you know that I like my fantasy takes
since D Hop's been back since he's came
back from was uh suspension he's been
like one of the most targeted uh
receivers so Sam we're just connecting
dots we're just connecting dots I can
see it happening yeah I like it uh Jay
Jones Raiders plus four
absolutely no chance give that guy f
no change yeah that that game uh that
game with Seahawks or bust for me I I
passed on it
um but no the Raiders are just now it's
hard to leave it's hard to win in
Seattle I'll be honest being a 49er fan
I've seen it year after year it's hard
to win in Seattle and I just don't think
the Raiders got what it takes to win the
Seattle yeah and the Seahawks obviously
kind of you know didn't play great their
last game but throughout the season
they've looked really really good
especially at home so yeah
I was looking for that from you guys I I
bet the Seahawks today so I really
needed that was Good Vibes for me so
thank you I love that uh Dewan Jackson
uh Jets Bears under 38 and a half
weather okay weather a total that total
solo I it's a really low number but I
really don't hate it you know the Jets
defense is really strong
um white versus Simeon so oh nice nice
little weather report
um we're not getting the double digits
into the wind which is tough but but we
may get some rain in the fourth quarter
the rain in Q4 that's important Sam that
is that is but yeah I don't hate it like
I I know that Mike White has been
upgrade over Zach Wilson but it's still
Mike White so I don't expect there to be
a ton of points whoa Sam says Mike White
to upgrade over Zach Wilson that's
awesome might be like the worst
quarterback in the entire league like
literally he might be the worst
he might he actually might that's the
thing he actually Baker Mayfield yeah
that's true we need to have like a
poverty between Zach Wilson and Baker
Mayfield
uh Hey one more Ryan let's do one more
and then we're getting out of here
unless she was ready to go already nah
we'll get one more uh one more Maddie 2x
uh you know this is uh anytime touchdown
score that I maybe would have liked for
them to drop during the segment but uh
Jalen waddle anytime touchdown
minus 115 on on
DraftKings I mean just off the
celebration alone it's yeah it's Vibes I
like it I like Good Vibes hey it's been
fun though guys today was fun I'm over
here I literally got
water coming from my eyes because I was
crying laughing so much my man Ryan
wants to get rich hopefully you get rich
today bro we're gonna hit both yeah
all our parlays gonna hit we're sitting
in the good Juju in the atmosphere make
sure you guys follow Ryan on Twitter
because he's going to Tweet out his
parlay uh but make sure you guys also
follow our parlay that we are riding
um Sam Sam gave us six locks at the
beginning of the show he gave us six
picks we're always riding with the man
the Mr Legend uh but my name is Greg ivy
for Sam Richmond and producer Ryan we
we out of here boys let's go get rich
Let's get some money peace
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]